[MUSIC]
Great ideas, where great ideas are ideas
that solve a problem in a unique way,
usually happen when two old ideas meet
together for the first time.
So great ideas are not new ideas.
They are usually a combination of existing
ideas.
And that's were brainstorming is powerful
because it brings together people
with different experiences so they can all
merge their ideas together.
So that's where design thinking become
effective because
it promotes that collaborative approach.
Bring people from different parts of the
organization together to bring you their
different knowledge, their different
expertise, and
provide their input into how you're gonna
solve a problem.
And by combining those ingredients
together, you can come up with new and
creative ways to solve a problem.
[MUSIC]
One thing that we have learned over the
years is that,
that process doesn't work with everyone.
So we have developed our own variation.
That also kinda work well with introverts.
So we can ask people to individually think
about 10 or
15 ways in which they can address the
problem.
Do that ahead of time.
And then meet as a group, share their
ideas.
And then engage into a more structured
brainstorm.
So a combination of individual idea
generation.
And combined group idea generation can
work really well.
[MUSIC]
It's all about putting yourself in your
user's shoes.
Spend time with your users.
Ask them questions.
Think ahead.
What do you want to learn?
And draft some interview questions.
And then engage in a conversation.
Don't make it an interview.
Engage in a conversation, but be prepared.
What do you want to learn?
Be a good listener.
And try to listen to the stories that your
user is gonna share with you.
Ask them about the last time they have
faced a challenging situation, and
how they addressed that challenging
situation.
That's a way for you to learn about your
user.
If they are willing to let you observe
them while they go
through their everyday life, that's a
great way to get deeper insights.
If you start discovering what is a problem
that you want to solve, and
they let you solve that problem for them,
or work with them to solve the problem.
That's a great way to really understand
what the problem is.
[MUSIC]
When you observe them, you see what they
actually go through.
But when you actually do it,
that's when you can really understand how
difficult some things may be.
Or what are the emotions that some
challenges are creating.
I may tell you that changing the tire of
my car is difficult but in order for
you to understand why it's difficult, you
would probably want to do it yourself.
Or, I may tell you that I find a
particular task challenging but you may be
able to better appreciate how challenging
it is when you try to do it yourself.
[MUSIC]
You want something that you can take back
to your user and
your user can interact with it.
They can feel it, they can play with it,
they can use it one way or another.
So the thing about quick and inexpensive
ways that you can make your early idea
usable, so you can go back to your user,
your customer, and get feedback.
And that feedback, now, is giving you
information.
Is this a good idea, or is this a bad
idea?
Oftentimes, from either your users'
reaction,
you may discover that the problem that you
thought they had is not there and
they have a different problem.
But you also learn more about what they
want, what their preferences are.
So you're using this process of generating
ideas and
taking them back to your user and getting
feedback is a way to define your
understanding of the problem but also
refine your idea.
[MUSIC]
In order for ideas to be valuable, the
economics need to work.
If it's a new product idea, you need to
build a viable business model, but
your idea may involve changing and
internal processes within an organization.
So you need to understand what are the
resources that you need to bring together,
and what is the case that you will need to
make to other people
to convince them to change that process.
If we are working on a new product idea,
the first question is, what is the value
proposition?
Write down the value proposition.
The second one is, who's gonna be your
customer?
Your customer segment.
Define your customer segment.
Third one is, how are you gonna reach
them?
And the fourth one is, how are you gonna
make money?
Now, the business model canvas has nine
elements, but
they have identified the first four that
you need to address.
Now, once you have this the value
proposition is something that you test
in your direct interaction of your user
with your prototype.
Through their reaction, what is the value
proposition that they see?
Does it match your value proposition?
The customer segment.
Once you define your customer segment,
the users that you talk to, must belong in
the customer segment you have defined.
So, if I believe that my customer segment
are teenagers, and
I'm talking to my colleagues at Stanford
and
sharing my idea with my colleagues at
Stanford, there seems alignment.
If I'm targeting teenagers,
the customers that I'm gonna be testing my
prototype with needs to be teenagers.
The third one is, how are you gonna reach
them?
That's an interesting one.
So, if my assumption is I'm gonna reach
them at the,
at the mall, then try to go to the mall
and find your users there.
The fourth one, pricing.
When you introduce a prototype, you can
tell them.
And when this becomes a full product, this
is the price that we're gonna charge.
And people are gonna react.
So, the fundament, the idea is there are
four
basic elements of the business model that
you need to prototype early.
Value proposition, customer segment,
channel of how you're
gonna find the customer, and revenue, how
you're gonna make money.
Make sure that as you start prototyping
and testing your prototype,
you do that in a way that is consistent
with those elements of the business model,
and that's how you can prototype a
business model.
[MUSIC]
There are some problems that are not
solvable.
You might not find a technology that's
gonna solve a particular problem.
But what you want to do is discover that
quickly.
So, the methodology doesn't necessarily
generate better ideas than
competing methodologies, if there are
competing methodologies.
It's just that this methodology allows you
to test your ideas quickly,
to see which ones hold promise.
[MUSIC]
Creativity is not rocket science.
Creativity is a structure systematic way
to solve problems.
So, the first thing that I would like to,
to, to execute is an organizations.
If you are a successful executive in an
organization,
you are successful because you are a good
problem solver.
So, if you are a good problem solver, you
are creative.
Creative doesn't mean you're Van Gogh or
Picasso, they are creative, in their own
discipline.
You can be creative in your own
So, if you can solve problems, you can be
creative.
[MUSIC]